then at
27 to suddenly decide I'm going to go be
a standup comic where the hell does that
come from man it's so weird well I I
think I I started standup comedy for two
very very very specific goals that I
wrote down when I was 27 and I still
have the piece of paper that very
specific the two things I always wanted
to do was sell out or perform at Madison
Square Garden the real Madison the arena
you know right upstairs cuz that's where
my father used to take me to basketball
games and we would Bond and talk so I
was like it' be cool for me to perform
here one day cuz by that time I knew I
wasn't going to make the NBA so I said
mad Square Garden and then to write a
sitcom about my father and my
relationship with my father because I
loved Everybody Loves Raymond and Ray
Romano and so I was like I want that
because I love the relationship he had
with his dad on the show and those were
the very like laser focused goals and
I'm telling you if I'm fortunate enough
to get those goals I don't know but I
would feel fulfilled and I could go back
to physical therapy maybe I wouldn't but
I'm just saying like I never felt this
if I don't make it or I never felt this
I got to be the best to ever do it I
always felt like what a chore that must
be to be the best to ever do it you got
to deal with there's so much to deal
with I I love my kids I got three kids I
love being in my kids life life I you
know I love you know my family and I'm
like I just have those two laser
specific goals which I am getting close
to now I am getting close to the Garden
I am getting close to the sitcom you
know anything can happen but it's the
closest I've ever been and I am having
this little um thing in my head where
I'm like wow if I get that are there new
goals I could make for myself because I
again I didn't have the Dream from when
I was a little kid I thought I was going
to be a history teacher I thought I was
going to be a gay history teacher and
straight stand straight stand up
comic